hi
welcome to our talk on how to take
charge of your sensitive data
my name is scott ellis and i'm a product
manager on google cloud's data security
and privacy team
now data powers your business
and data is one of your greatest assets
but it can also be one of your biggest
risks
and today we're going to talk about how
you can take charge of your data
and we're going to cover topics like how
you can discover and classify your
sensitive data
you know we feel that understanding your
sensitive data is the first step in
protecting it
and once you have that kind of
visibility
we're going to talk about how you can
manage your data risk
using things like security policy
confidential processing
and data obfuscation
and ultimately we want to be able to do
this at scale so that you can focus on
your business and again really focus on
the outcomes
now to do this automation is key
and again if you want to know your data
and if you want to understand your
sensitive data so that you can better
protect it
on-demand scans and manual review can
help
however the challenge is that your data
is growing as your business is growing
and that means your data footprint is
growing and it's more challenging to
manage it
and so you really need a way to
automatically discover and classify your
data
and today we're going to talk about how
you can get automatic discovery
automatic inspection
automatic classification and automatic
data profiling and really automatic dlp
and this is now available for bigquery
and it's powered by our cloud dlp
platform
and what that means is that you can get
an understanding of your data risk
across your entire bigquery footprint
and that means you can understand where
you have maybe low risk data which could
mean that there's no evidence of
sensitive data or that it's got extra
protections in place
or where you have moderate or high risk
this could be where you have evidence of
sensitive data like pii
or evidence of unstructured data or free
text that might be inside of your your
tables
or where you have highly sensitive data
something like pii like credit card
numbers or financial data
and what automatic dlp will do is
generate rich insights for each table
and column across your org and that's
really important because you want to get
that visibility across all of your
tables all of your columns so you can
really understand your data risk
now here's an example of a column
profile for a table
where we're seeing different types of
metrics that indicate the type of risk
the type of sensitivity
and it includes our deal the dlp's
predicted info type
and this gives an indication in this
table that we see evidence of a credit
card number an email address
and a couple columns that have evidence
of a person name this kind of data type
can really help you understand your data
or take the next step to protecting it
now this automatic visibility with dlp
really means that you get continuous
monitoring
that means that tables are picked up
automatically so as you're creating new
projects new data sets and new tables in
bigquery
automatic dlp will pick them up
automatically and profile them for you
and it's designed as a fully managed
service to have low overhead what that
means is that there's no jobs to manage
or orchestrate
and you can enable this directly in the
cloud console
it's also been built with data residency
in mind
and again if you're turning this on
across your entire org you may have data
in different regions different
geographic regions and dlp will inspect
that data in the geographic region that
you have set
for your bigquery tables it will also
generate the profiles and store them in
that same geographic region and that way
you can ensure that your data stays
where you want it even when it's being
inspected and profiled by dlp
and lastly this is google driven and
what that means is that we figure out
how to inspect and profile your data
so you can focus again on the outcomes
great now let's see this in action
and now let's see a demo of this
automatic dlp and for this let's meet
angie is a data compliance officer for a
large online retailer that serves
customers across the globe
angie oversees how data is collected
shared and used across all departments
angie's company is growing and their
data is growing with them
they've chosen to use bigquery as their
data warehouse to power most of their
analytics and business needs and usage
of bigquery is spread across several
departments and project teams
and again these teams are creating new
projects new data sets new tables
constantly as part of their business
and angie wants to know how can i gain
visibility into the sensitive data
across my org
and for this we're going to use our
automatic dlp what this means is you can
now enable cloud dlp across your org
and your entire bigquery footprint
so what that means is that you can turn
dlp on across your organization as we're
seeing here
across specific organization folders you
know maybe these represent departments
or different parts of your organization
or individual projects now bigquery data
lives inside tables and data sets that
reside inside these projects so
depending on where you turn this on
you'll get coverage across all that data
when this is enabled cloud dlp will
automatically pick up new data
pick up existing data profile it
and give you those insights into your
interior sensitive data
now enabling this is easy and can be
done completely in the cloud console ui
for this you would at the org level
angie would navigate to security and
then data loss prevention
and then click on the scan org
link here now let's go ahead and see
what that looks like i'm going to switch
over here to my test project we're going
to click on scan organization
now we can configure this in one click
and take care of everything for you
but let's go ahead and walk through the
custom configuration just so you can see
the options that you have
the first option you have here is to
choose whether you want to scan your
entire organization
or if you want to browse and select
individual folders to scan for now we'll
just scan our entire organization
now this service is built with cloud
data loss prevention or cloud dlp so you
can use your existing inspection
templates
or you can create a new one but this is
powered by the same
info type detectors that we have for
cloud dlp so you can select from our
built-in detectors
or define custom ones of your own
additionally you can select the third
option
which will run a set of our most popular
kind of default
detectors
and just simply select that option
and next you can see
the permissions needed to run this scan
now we're very transparent about the
permissions that are needed here we can
also create those for you or you can set
those permissions individually again
just depending on what is best for your
organization
and next let's talk a little bit about
data residency so data residency is
crucial to your data and we've built
this you know cloud dlp from the ground
up to support data residency and that
holds true for this automatic
solution for bigquery
what that means is that when you have
data in a certain geographic region you
know configured in bigquery to be in a
certain geographic region
dlp will scan data in that same region
so the process of scanning your data
happens in the same geographic region
additionally the profile output
will be stored in the same geographic
region as your bigquery data and again
this allows you to maintain that date of
residency
additionally we give you the control to
to decide where to store the actual
configuration data which is what we're
configuring here again we want to make
sure you have good insight and control
of your data to know where and how it's
being processed
now if i click create here this is going
to enable
this new service for my entire
organization
which is great
however i've already done that so i'm
going to go ahead and click cancel
and let's take a look at what the
results look like now in this particular
organization i only have these six
projects here
and each of these projects has bigquery
data
data sets and tables inside them
now here at the project view i'm just
getting a high level view
of the tables and kind of a summary of
the risk and sensitivity in them let's
go ahead and click on one of these
projects
and now what i'm seeing is every data
set and table that is in that project
and the associate metrics at the table
level including things like our data
risk assessments whether this data is
public what kind of encryption it has
row count
and i can also click on one of these
tables to go even further i'm going to
click on this table
and this will take me into the column
level profile
here we see detailed metrics for every
column in that table
including dlp's predicted info type
which again is if we can figure out that
this column looks like a particular data
type we actually label that column here
with that type so here we're seeing a
column
with credit card numbers email addresses
and person name it looks like we have a
first name and a last name
as well as metrics
around that
for data risk sensitivity and some
additional metrics around whether or not
this column looks like it has free text
or it's you know kind of unstructured
maybe a comment field
as well as uniqueness and no percent
estimates
now these are important because imagine
this column of credit card numbers we
also see that there is a uniqueness
score of one
and that's a high uniqueness score
which indicates that this column likely
contains unique credit card numbers in
every row
which would be different than a low
uniqueness score where maybe that same
value was repeated over and over
multiple times we also see that with an
estimated null percent of zero that
means that this column looks like it's
pretty well populated and there's not a
lot of null or sparsely populated data
in these columns but again this is the
kind of rich insights that you get
with the column level profile
as well as the table and project level
profiles and all of this again will be
continuously running and generating as
new tables are created
across your org
great let's go back to angie
now angie needed an automated solution
and angie chose to use cloud dlp's new
service to automatically discover
inspect and profile
their bigquery tables for sensitive data
like pii and this automatic dlp service
will pick up new projects data sets and
tables automatically
and the outcome is that angie's team now
has clear visibility into their
sensitive data and can make more
informed decisions about how it's
protected used processed and shared
and that concludes our demo of the new
automatic dlp for bigquery
great we've now just shown you how you
can get org-wide visibility with the new
automatic dlp
and again this can give you
clear visibility into your sensitive
data so that you can make more informed
decisions
and that's now available for bigquery
now that you have that clear visibility
into your data let's figure out some
ways to manage your data risk and reduce
your data risk
so first
how can i enable more fine-grained
access control and protection
so now that you know where your
sensitive data is maybe you want to go
in and
employ column level access policy
and using bigquery policy tags you can
enable column level access enforcement
which can help you strike a balance
between
access and security
so an example policy is shown here
and these policies have a taxonomy or a
hierarchy to them what that means is
that we can put an element like credit
card number
underneath or inside of a higher level
policy like financial and that allows
you to grant access and manage your
policy at that higher level
while enabling you to tag the data at
the lower level at credit card number
let's see this in action
so
here's an example here where we're
seeing a table where we have tagged
four of the columns in here with a tag
for person name email address and credit
card number
and we have turned on enforcement of a
policy using bigquery policy tags so
that users can only access those
sensitive elements if they have the
right permission
and what that means is if i have access
to this table but i don't have access to
those particular columns
i'll still be able to query the table
and in this case maybe run an analysis
on the payment type
and the transaction amount
but i won't be able to access a
sensitive elements like the pii here
that we see unless i have that
additional access control and again
that's a way you can find that balance
between
access and security and overall reduce
and manage some of your data risk
another technique is to go in and use
obfuscation or masking and this is
something that you can do with cloud dlp
and it's a technique we call
de-identification
now de-identification includes a set of
transforms like redaction
masking
tokenization format preserving
encryption
date shifting bucketing and more
and these transformations are designed
to actually manipulate and transform
your data
in order to reduce the risk so
for example in this before and after
animation that we're saying we're seeing
these techniques applied to a table in
this case a table that has four columns
and we're applying transformations
across the entire column in these first
three columns again in this our goal
here is to reduce the risk of the data
so we are manipulating and transforming
the sensitive information and replacing
it with something that is obfuscated
now in that fourth column
we're combining the power of dlp's
inspection capability with the masking
so that we can actually go into these
unstructured comment fields find the
sensitive element and only mask that
sensitive element
and this is something that you can do
because we've combined that inspection
capability
with the data masking capability all in
one platform
otherwise you'd have to potentially
redact the entire comment field column
but instead you can actually go in and
redact only the sensitive information in
line
another question is how can i improve
protection and process my data in a
confidential manner
again now that you have visibility into
where your sensitive data exists
you can use confidential processing
to process that more securely an example
of that would be confidential data proc
which offers encryption in use
which can easily add security
protections to your most sensitive data
workloads
here's an example where we are turning
on confidential compute
with a simple command line flag as we
create and launch our dataproc pipeline
now confidential dataproc is now in ga
now dataproc is a fully managed and
highly scalable
service for running things like apache
spark flink and presto and confidential
data proc adds that data encryption in
use again to protect your most sensitive
data
and it does this by using confidential
vms to provide that in-line memory
encryption
and this is powered by amd's secure
encrypted virtualization processors
and this brings us to the end of our
talk on how to take charge of your
sensitive data and we'll leave you with
a few key takeaways and action items
first
automatic dlp is now available for
bigquery and can give you insight into
your entire bigquery footprint across
your org
you can get started
in the cloud console by navigating to
security and then data loss prevention
or you can read our documentation at
cloud.google.com
dlp
you can also check out
obfuscation and masking or or we call
de-identification
also at cloud.google.com dlp
and you can read more about confidential
processing which is available with vms
gke
and now in ga for dataproc at
cloud.google.com
confidential hyphen computing
thank you again for joining us today and
we're happy to be part of your journey
as you take care of your sensitive data
thank you
you